you don't have to make a heading for
this because it will just continue from
yesterday but if you want to you can
just say auxilary angle because i want
you to remember this question we've done
this question we did it a few days ago 5
sine x minus cot x equals 2 we know how
to solve this we have solved this what
method did we use we use that tan theta
on to epsilon students that's right also
known as user t results so what we said
was introduced substitutions then you
can call that to see on one p square 1
minus T squared on one plus t-squared
and in off you go you solve the T and
then you can go from there I'll go back
and also tell you John
so we know how to do this into yourself
it's fine I'm really long-winded but at
least you can solve it whereas without
that we would like I don't even know
what it's done however now you guys do
it obviously angle which gives you
another point of access with a staying
question
I'm going to let you decide by the end
of this whether you prefer to eat my
tears off or buy over to the ankle I'd
say just on the number of lives of
working so that was the same but I
thought to you you feel wonderful
difficult to the other each hand kind of
on weak points so why we get started I
think it doesn't fire sign explains
quadratics I am going to take this thing
on the left hand side and I'm going to
replace them with something using my
auxilary angle knowledge that you guys
know sines and cosines there's four
identities that you can choose your
right sign a plus B sine a minus B cos a
plus B cos a minus B which one fits this
this we're going to be sine a minus B
because of a sign up front and in the
sign of the middle the pot - it's a mic
so therefore I'm going to say let this
be equal to our side X once again 1
minus alpha 1 snap-loc okay and I'm just
going to stay a restriction on R and
alpha just so it's clear these letters
that are just introducing their numbers
they're not variables so I'm going to
proceed with this just like I had before
this first slide you know get quite
repetitive it's acquired because it's
labeled us to compared I've got sine and
cosine on the left hand side I also have
signs
and cosine on the right hand side so far
so good I just thought the extensions
that you're right okay so nothing so
then I can say by comparison
I'm looking for signs on the left hand
signs on the right the coefficient of
sine X on the left hand side is 5 the
coefficient of sine X on the right hand
side is r cos alpha do you agree so I
can say those two must be the same one
month with young I'll do the same thing
to cosine I notice that both of them are
negative the negative on the right hand
side it's negative 1 sorry on the left
hand side it's negative 1 on the bright
side here but for all the pieces
it's R sine alpha yes - Rob however
could isn't - on both sides I don't mean
to worry about the - to decide I'm just
going to write R sine alpha equals 1
okay but please no I guess it would be
fooled to say minus R sine alpha equals
minus 1 but did their carefully since
you yourself chose this expansion to
match this side that's why I don't
really need to worry dive business ok so
I've got two simultaneous equations that
means I have definitely evidence names
do you remember
to eliminate one of variables what
should I do - I combined them I should
square each one and then
as them so I'm going to say what I'm
doing I'm squaring each one then I do on
the left hand side I will end up with
this but I just done the factorization
wants that but I don't think it's too
much build leads to like that to that
what do I have on the right hand side
now this is important this part here
just equals 1 so R squared is 26 so now
I have given our respondent is it will
be them so it's like the air sucking out
the entry level and I'll keep my t what
is our signified
what's its significance reviewing it
it's the amplitude of my new function
once I put these things together okay so
far so good
I pull out what am I going to do with
that I'm going to something that's bad
so that I can find alpha so I'm going to
solve our into
both of these equations okay I'm going
to go straight to Khan's alpha equals
five on this and sine alpha equals one
objects how do you feel that okay you
see what I've done a quick Marion I've
divided through by arms okay I notice
both cos and sine alpha cut positive
right from alpha sine alpha are positive
so which quadrant must I view I'm in the
first quadrant because of the a for all
quadrants and that's kind of a point
that I chose this form not only does
this for me I've you've let negatives it
also need this will be the smallest
alpha can possibly be I don't know how
many of you did you did the challenge I
said what happens if you choose the
wrong poor you'll still get something
you'll just get enormous angles that I
like third or fourth quadrants still
true just messy to deal with and I'd
rather have small numbers rather than
big one okay I know it's in first
quadrant this is clearly not an exact
value so reach for your calculator and
to find out but you can use either these
equations right you can just go should
side this number or should cause this
done I only get one decimal place
oh boy three degrees approximately